t'adresse il est temps maintenant de
retrouver l'équipe du brin de bonheur de
retour à strasbourg nous certains bancs
sont ce soir à l'esplanade c'est la
première halte d'une tournée à travers
les quartiers de la ville
amour un petit
pas de vainqueur
y at il une relation de cause à effet
mais pour notre retour sur strasbourg la
grisaille s'est à nouveau installé
espérons que tout à l'heure au parc de
la citadelle la pluie ne sera pas de la
partie au fait saviez-vous qu'à
l'esplanade au milieu de ces tours sans
âme il y avait encore quelques coins de
campagne
je suis sûr que vous ne les connaissez
pas en bordure du quai les alpes on
trouve un petit village construit au
début des années 30 pour les officiers
de l'armée du rhin si si ce havre de
verdure fait partie du quartier de
l'esplanade 25 maison avec un petit
jardinet entretenu amoureusement par
leurs occupants premier contraste
l'autre se situe rue duke salle dans le
quartier suédois construit entre 60 et
62 un petit square où trône une sirène
oeuvres de l'artiste henninger au début
ce quartier était surtout occupé par les
rapatriés d'algérie un îlot de la thur
au beau milieu de l'ensemble de
l'esplanade qui compte 85 tours et 15000
habitants
mais les espaces verts ne sont pas
totalement absent le quartier en dehors
du parc de la citadelle en possède 11
hectares
dommage qu'il soit isolée par le
gigantisme urbain caractéristique des
années 60 avant la construction de cet
ensemble résidentiel les militaires de
la caserne géraudot régné sur le
quartier façonné en partie par vauban
encore lui de se passer reste quelques
souvenirs
à l'époque les enfants n'avaient pas de
sable et de balançoire pour jouer rester
l'imagination et l'espièglerie parfois
inconsciente maintenant peuvent jouer en
toute sécurité
il est arrivé ils ont des bicyclettes ou
ou envahissons toute possibilité de
jouer tous les jeux à l'époque et bien
en 45 quand ce parc était comme était
tout à fait dévasté et bien les enfants
jouer hélas avec des fumigènes et des
balles qui mettait dans l'eure dans les
fumigènes et qui venaient plus
discrètement posé à côté des pêcheurs
pour les effrayer au grand risque de
leur vie et de la vidéo décidément les
artistes ont du mal à s'extraire de leur
aventure campagnarde
il s'attache au moindre souvenir même
les plus insolites comme celui qui
évoque la future maman
moi j'ai suivi toute cette tournée vu
mon état en voiture parce que les
carrioles avec les soubresauts j'avais
pas vraiment droit mais j'ai pu noter en
voiture en suivant le cortège un
phénomène tout à fait particulier c'est
le phénomène du crottin de cheval
effectivement je suivais les six chevaux
qui a eu sur la tournée et je suis vélo
que les traces du crottin de cheval
ce qui m'a étonné que j'ai fait le
calcul je suis allé voir d'aidé qui s'y
connaît vraiment crottin de cheval
ce qui m'a étonné c'est qu'en faisant le
calcul on est arrivé jusqu'à je crois
800 kg de crottin de cheval égrainé sur
les routes de france d'allemagne et de
strasbourg et personne en ce temps de
crise personne n'a une idée de suivre la
caravane derrière avec un balai et un
saut je sais pas quel prix du kilo du
crottin de cheval mais je crois que
quelqu'un aurait pu se faire de bonnes
vacances après cela je me dirais pas que
le tango de la portugaise de la tournée
se situe au même niveau
bien que comme à son habitude le
scabreux soient présents dans sa chanson
mais seulement à la fin pour être
honnête la petite malle ou à de la
présence sur scène ce sera certainement
une des révélations de la tournée
les hommes aiment bien les femmes en
retard je suis au près dans le cas si
que l' agence m'avait indiqué il met en
vente au bout du bar très creuse brillé
lors son costard l'annoncent par l'aide
à l'hidalgo j'avais des me tromper
disque rend à nantes en pis je commence
fort
car il ya si peu d'un enfant
j'ai la clé hélas un tel sort
laissez-moi direction abordés
c'est partout photo
c'est bien
c'est quelque chose à briquet
mais six mois
j'ai le parfum j'appelle généreux
l'adresse de lagence vian
dans les fonds des mots caire je
l'attendais toujours particulièrement ce
soir le spectacle aura lieu à 21h parc
de la citadelle à l'esplanade
en espérant que le temps sera de la
partie salut les p'tits loups